[Music]
well hello everyone
welcome to the white house it's the
biggest crowd we've had since we got
here
[Applause]
i'm joe biden i'm jill biden's husband
i'm proud of it
welcome to women's history month
celebration we're honored to
have what may well be
the most inspiring event we've had at
the white house so far
i've often said that america's strength
is not just the example of our power but
the power of our example and i mean that
look at uh i was going to say
look at this stage but that's enough too
look at the stage
but there's been a little change in the
arrangement who's on the stage because
of the first lady's husband uh
contracting covet but uh look at this
room and what you see
that's right
she's fine
the second lady the first gentleman
how about that
anyway an incredible group of members of
congress led by nancy pelosi the first
woman speaker
[Applause]
i believe will be considered one of the
greatest speakers in our history
[Applause]
[Music]
she knows that i mean i've been saying
it for you
and members of the most diverse cabinet
in history of this country
[Applause]
the first
[Applause]
to have an equal number of women and men
in the cabinet
i'm enormously proud of this team
one person i'm particularly proud of is
was going to be introducing me is kamala
harris
[Applause]
as i said kamala chose not to take a
chance since her husband had contracted
covert all he's feeling very well i'm
told
uh by the way uh when he touched he's
fine but out of abundance of caution she
decided she wasn't going to join us
today
but let's send her our love because
she's something else
and i know how proud she is of our our
team avril haynes the first woman to
lead our intelligence community is
director of mike
[Applause]
she does everything in secret that's why
she didn't want to stand up
the former governor jennifer grant home
the energy department
[Applause]
i often kid her and i wasn't kidding
early on when i was seeking the
nomination
had she been born in america she'd be
standing here and i'd be sitting there
she was a former governor of the state
of
michigan
michigan wrong
she was a former state she was a
governor
i'm teasing but we often kidded about it
and
isabel guzman small business
administration
catherine ty u.s trade representative
she knows how to cut a deal
[Applause]
cece rouse chair of the council of
economic advice
a number of members are not here today
because they're out traveling on behalf
of administration jalen janet yellen the
first female secretary of the treasury
deb holland the first native american
person in
cabinet secretary
as
the
gina armando former governor leading the
commerce department
[Applause]
why should flood housing and urban
development
[Applause]
if i stole any more members of congress
i would have been in real trouble with
men
and shalonda young newly confirmed
ago
[Applause]
come on just stand up
where's yolanda
where are you were she
she i guess she's not okay lead the
officer management budget
and ambassador thomas greenhouse
greenfield excuse me who is uh at the
united nations and does an incredible
job
it's not just the cabinet
we have women in senior roles in every
level here at the white house across the
administration many of whom are here
today and something i'm very proud of i
kept my commitment to be nominate the
first black woman of the supreme court
[Applause]
[Music]
and that's not all
we have confirmed more black women to
the circuit court of appeal
than every previous administration
combined
[Applause]
as a matter of fact
75 of my judicial nominees are women
[Music]
it matters
it matters
above all we see the power of each and
every one of you and the example that
they in fact
give the whole country you know i want
to thank you all for being here
at home and all those are helping me
around the helping administration around
the world
it uh that includes a special guest of
the first lady
uh and the first lady of iceland eliza
reed eliza where are you
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right
she is a real champion for gender
equality
we had a nice long talk
women's history month is an opportunity
to honor the legacy
the vision and the achievements of
trailblazing women and girls who've
built shaped and strengthened the
character very character this nation
and despite hardships and exclusion and
discrimination
women run the right won the right to
vote campaigned against injustice
shattered countless barriers and
expanded the possibilities for all
americans i think you underestimate all
you've done
they came before us and they're all here
here today from all across the country
as well especially everyone who has
gotten through this pandemic front-line
workers and service members researchers
and teachers
[Applause]
caregivers
leaders in our community
today i'm honored to be with some of the
world's
greatest soccer players who happen to be
women
[Applause]
the us women's national team both past
and present please i'm gonna ask you
come up on the stage
because everybody else is standing this
is uh they've won world cups the
olympics gold medal gold medals and you
know and for after much much much too
long
equal pay
today's equal pay day
they just came for an event
that discussed all administration's
efforts to close the pay gap so thank
you so much and by the way
[Applause]
all right
thank you
and look we're doing so by expanding
access to good paying jobs
lower costs for child care and older
care so women can get back to work or
their families can have economic
security
and earlier today i signed an executive
order to promote efforts to achieve pay
equality and pay equity for employees of
federal contractors
and it's my hope that this sets an
example for all private companies to
follow as well that's the purpose of
what i do
[Applause]
let me just close with this gender
equality is not a woman's issue alone
it benefits everybody that's a fact that
benefits everyone
our society our economy and our country
and i hope you're able to
walk through the wonderful exhibit we
have downstairs celebrating women's
history month
and the history of the journey of
america
back in fair back in february i was in
lorraine ohio outside of cleveland
to talk about a new infrastructure law
that was going to transform our nation
it was a day before the birthday of uh
lorraine's most famous one of her most
famous daughters nobel prize pulitzer
prize no nobel prize winner pulitzer
prize winner one of jill's favorite
authors tony morris
tony azales was also the mother-in-law
of
dr rouse one of our nation's top
economic thinkers
ms morrison left us words to live by she
said
we've got more yesterdays than anybody
we need some kind of tomorrow
we need some kind of tomorrow
downstairs is the display honoring tony
morrison and that's singular belief in
tomorrow that singular belief that
america in america
anything is possible i was once asked by
xi jinping in china how could i define
america i said yes in one word god's
truth and one word
possibilities we believe anything is
possible in this country and that
singular power of example shows our
daughters our granddaughters not a
single thing a man can do that a woman
can't do
as well or better
and by the way i can honestly without
fear of contradiction from the time my
daughter was born our daughter was born
so the time our four granddaughters were
born i've told them every day they could
listen that there's not a single thing
they can't do and i mean that from the
bottom of my heart and they are living
proof of that truth i want to start
talking about my granddaughters now if i
can't wait
hello especially the women i'm honored
to introduce
and who has more influence on them and
has set an example that uh
i think i'm just fortunate they're
fortunate to
have witnessed and be part of and with
that let me introduce the first lady of
the united states before she comes up
i want you to know
everybody knows
i love her more than she loves me
[Laughter]
i'm going to tell the story
when jill first got
to the vice president's office as those
of you who are from washington know
you walk down the steps from the
eisenhower building and you're looking
right into the vice president's office
and the windows i think are 16 feet high
and they have 12 big panes of glass
and four of them going across the office
i think it's four
and uh
and so jill's favorite day
is
a year is valentine's day
and so she had gotten as a professor a
teacher she's still teaching full-time a
teacher she got that erasable
paint you can you know use
and she on every window every window she
got the maintenance guy to bring up a
ladder and every window she put a big
heart
and she said
joe loves jill
i swear to god
in every single window
well my press person came to me is
because she did it in the evening
and and she the night before valentine's
day and he said look they want you to go
on cbs tomorrow morning to talk about
valentine's day we think you should do
it you know her name the the interviewer
was juju chang
and juju
we're sitting there in the vice
president's
large office with all the shades pulled
and dark and just the lights on the you
know the the clique delights and and
we're about knee to knee
and while we're getting ready juju chang
looks at me and says
you know everybody says you and your
wife have a great love affair going
i said i think so i said but everybody
knows i love her more than she loves me
and she looked me straight in the eye
good morning she said that's what they
say
ladies and gentlemen the love of my life
and the life of my love
[Applause]
thank you
thank you
thank you very much
thank you
please
oh gosh
thank you mr president
you know i never get tired of saying
that
and eliza i'm so glad to meet you and i
i taught we were talking to eliza
earlier and uh i she was saying she had
four children and i said no wonder
you're on the road
you know looking around this room at so
many women who have blazed trails and
shattered glass ceilings i'm so grateful
that all of you have joined us and gosh
it's been so long since i've seen so
many of you due to the pandemic it's
just great
that you've joined us today so thank you
to all of you who are here and i really
we really appreciate your coming
and i can't yet you know i can't help
but think of a woman whose name isn't
in our history books
and that's my mother
she was a stay-at-home mom of the mother
of five girls and she we lived in a
suburb of philadelphia
and she spent her days trying to
complete a to-do list
that was never quite done
but she was a really a terrible cook
you know we ate frozen fish sticks and
boiled hot dogs
and uh i don't know if any of you
remember uh she used to make junket does
anybody here remember junket that
pudding
a couple
everybody's like no we don't remember
that
anyway it was horrible
but uh she dressed the dinner table with
fresh flowers and china each night to
make it feel special and she was witty
and quick to laugh and she was so kind
and she knew exactly what to say to me
when my world was falling apart
and that's what i missed the most how i
could call her when i was hurt or angry
when i felt like i'd never you know
lived up to the person that i wanted to
be
and just the sound of her voice
could make me feel that everything was
okay
she never asked me to follow in her
footsteps
only she made sure that i could find my
own way and she'd be there rooting for
me
i though she left before i was done
needing her
i felt
her strength i still feel her strength
inside of me
and i see her fire in our daughter
ashley
and i know that you know my mom never
stopped cheering me on
and we're all here today
because someone believed in us
you know it was our mothers our nanas
and teachers and mentors because someone
taught us to be brave
and we are here to be those women for
someone else
in big historic ways becoming as the
vice president says those firsts but not
lasts
and in small ways too
helping our daughters believe in a world
we haven't won yet
showing our sons
that it's their work too
[Applause]
taking risks even when we might fail
because we know that there is a young
girl
who needs to see us try
today we honor the women who made us
and the women
we
make we know that there is still far to
travel but we keep moving
guided by the strong hands of the women
who came before us
continuing the path that they forged
with sweat and pain
and yes love
so thank you for being here
thank you for celebrating this moment
with us
may you never forget the women who are
cheering you on
and may your voice
be that ovation for the girls who come
next thank you
[Applause]
thanks everybody
[Applause]
because
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
uh
thank you
[Music]
you